nigeria's president mohammad isaf voted
to choose his successor
after two five-year terms he could have
run for the third term
but is choosing to step down while other
leaders in the region
desperately cling to power the election
is coming at a difficult time for his
nation
a point not lost on the outgoing
president
nigeria is facing immense challenges
security challenges
demographic challenges climate
challenges economic and social
development challenges
including the immediate sanitary
challenge posed by kobit-19
i'm convinced that to face these
challenges we need strong and stable
democratic institutions
as voting is underway seven electoral
officials were killed in tillaberry
a region closed tunisia borders with
mali
and burkina faso their vehicle was hit
by a roadside bomb
that also injured three others there had
been fears of violence even before the
boat
especially in the region that seen
several attacks by armed groups
this is the man the ruling party chose
to take over from the incumbent
muhammad bazum a trusted ally of
president yusufu
and former minister of both the interior
and foreign ministries
i have just voted after spending several
weeks in the provinces
i visited several villages and had a lot
of contact and i wish for calm during
this election
discipline and that the winner be
blessed with good fortune
i wish for good fortune to be on my side
of course and have many reasons to
believe that it is on my side
i therefore look ahead to the future
with serenity and a lot of calm
his challenger is nigeria's former
president and prime minister
maman usman was running for the fifth
time seeking to come back to the post
he held 25 years ago guzman who voted in
his home region of zinder
warned against election fraud
if citizens notice that these elections
have once more been fraudulent elections
i fear that the situation will be
difficult to manage last time people
were disciplined
we ourselves contributed to making sure
it was calm and serene and tolerated the
results of a fraudulent election
but this time since you asked me my
feelings my feeling is that the
population is no longer ready to
tolerate fraudulent elections
in the first round of parliamentary and
presidential elections held on december
27th
mohammed bazum secured 39.3 of the vote
while osman got 16.9 percent but without
a clear majority
it forced a runoff ahead of sunday's
election the two candidates went into
strategic alliances with nij's smaller
political parties
with a view to forming coalitions
analysts suggest the governing party
whose party won 80 of the 171 seats in
parliament
may age out the opposition which has
only seven seats
but the candidate of the opposition
insist the voters
that have the final say the result is
expected in a matter of days
when the election commission declares a
winner two weeks after that
the constitutional court will validate
or reject the results as announced
but for many voters what's important now
is to have a leader
who can quickly address the problems of
poverty unemployment
and violence by armed groups ahmedi ruiz
al jazeera